hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge gold
simulator da habe ich in der letzten
folge nicht richtig geschafft haben weil
wir da hin
das war ganz schön eng kollege in der
letzten folge waren wir da in dem
nowitzki testing facility ja die letzte
folge verlinkt ich euch mal hier da
könnt ihr euch das noch mal anschauen
das war echt wichtig weil wir ein
fahrrad gefunden haben und damit eine
menge quatsch gemacht haben was macht
sie denn hier die ich wollte heute
eigentlich das coffee staines du dir
suchen allerdings ist es ja viel
interesse hat geredet es ist glaube ich
viel interessanter diese personen zu
beobachten ich frage mich ob die beim
ich stolpert wenn die darf ich
vorstellen meine damen und herren halb
mensch was macht ihr hier green day die
stadt jetzt seit drei stunden diesen
pfeiler an
ist ein leben in dir vorhanden kann ich
nicht mal
die sonne einfach mist da oben ein baum
aus es tut mir sehr leid mitte
ich gebe es auf dieses spiel kam ich
nicht mehr überzeugen sie geht über die
straße in gilt sowohl im rücken
gebrochen gegen reto wyss komplett
lebensmüde du person ihren über die
straße laufen
den könnte ich hab dich gewarnt ich habe
nicht mehrmals ingrid nein alter ingrid
tobis mein held ich wollte gerade
wirklich kurzes baumhaus erkunden um
mich ein komplett dem baumhaus zu widmen
aber ingrid ist eigentlich viel
interessanter
heikel da ich mich nicht komplett ingrid
widmen möchte allerdings auch nicht
komplett im baumhaus habe ich mir
gedacht ich nehme ingrid einfach mit zum
baumhaus das findet sie glaube ich auch
ganz cool ich weiß jetzt allerdings
nicht wie ich da irgendwie hoch kommen
soll
vielleicht mit trampolin man muss damit
ich übelst aufpassen dass man immer
wieder irgendwie das trampolin trifft
weil diese im griff nicht immer alle
möglichen richtungen zieht aber ich
glaube jetzt sind hier verdammte scheiße
vielleicht schaffen wir es dieses mal
ins baum also mein gott ich habe mut
gemacht das kann doch nicht sein ich
will doch einfach nur da ingrid ich will
da rein nicht deinen kopf oder was auch
immer das da ist aber wir wollen uns ja
heute dem coffee steyn entwickler studio
widmen was laut euren kommentaren
dieses da sind nämlich die ganzen leute
drinnen die ok ich kann das überhaupt
nicht steuern
ich hab sogar motion an gemacht wie
mache ich das wieder haus gegen den
blöden knopf ja soll ich denn jetzt
getan
man kann nämlich oben in dem coffee
staines du dir hier kann man andere
flexible zocken in gretesch noch da und
wir können jetzt happy go spielen und
einfach er benutzen
ich hab verloren da können wir jetzt
hier
happy go becher verläuft das ist
tatsächlich schwieriger als es aussieht
ich habe schon wieder verloren um mein
gott da muss ich hin kriegen die musste
ich hin kriegen muss sich in kriegen
mein gott da ist die einst die und da
haben wir die zwei und da mir die ich
bin 170000 das ist gut das ist
eigentlich das einzige was in diesem
video machen wollte dann kamen im gerät
ich hab mir das ganze ein bisschen
krasser hier vorgestellt was aber
letztendlich richtig packt hier gerade
auch irgendwie übels rum bevor ich
allerdings noch weiter herum haben wir
machen werk ich wollte einfach nur ich
habe ein laserschwert ich wollte
eigentlich nur hier den kalender nehmen
allerdings liegen da meine beiden later
ja ich habe mein zweites diese beiden
laserschwerter habe ich die sind einmal
in einmal rot und blau
hat mir disney zugesandt im zuge des
neuen star wars film zwei warte man
konnte bot das video das video kommt
glaublich am donnerstag und da war ich
nämlich ich bin ein paar produzieren
dabei ist jetzt dann auf der premiere
tatsächlich nicht in berlin bei dem star
wars film und ich glaube es war gut
also ich weiß nicht welchen star wars
fan bin
die haben ja heißt zwei lichtschwerter
zugesandten keine ahnung es soll aber
eigentlich viel mehr um den kalender
gehen heute ist donnerstag 17 deswegen
machen wir das siebzehnte türchen auf
wohinter sich eine striptease stange
verbirgt es war doch alles trip die
stange sondern einfach einen jacken
ständer bzw für taschen und so weiter
ich das einfach in unsere landschaft die
reihe und am bücherstand sagen meine
lieben freunde wenn euch das video
gefallen hat wen ich meine bewertungen
freuen schreibt mir die kommentare ob
ihr den kalender überhaupt cool findet
ob ich damit aufhören solle doch
weitermachen soll was ihr vom neuen star
wars film haltet wenn ihr schon drin was
ist überhaupt schon draußen ich weiß es
nicht und dann sehen wir uns in einem
nächsten video wieder alles klar